here's a teacher explaining why
parents should just shut up and let the
school system sexually indoctrinate
their children here's what she says
I have a thought now I know the trolls
are going to be like oh she should have
stopped there but I'm not gonna do that
so there's a lot of controversy about
whether or not sex education health
education relationships gender all that
stuff should be taught in the classroom
here's what I think
you you as in parents send their kids to
school to learn math Reading Writing
history
science from a professional right
but in the same token a lot of people
who do that
also think that they're experts in
sexuality education because they've had
kids
with all due respect just because you
had kids does not mean that you are a
sexuality education expert it does not
mean you are an expert in sex it does
not mean you are an expert in the body
it does not mean you are an expert in
gender it does not mean you are an
expert in relationships
so the same way that we're sending our
kids to school to learn these skills
these life skills like math and
quadratic equations and calculus and
whatever else from a professional we
also need to be ensuring that our
students are learning information about
their health about identity about very
complex issues from a professional
I mean like it makes sense it makes
sense
okay well if you say it makes sense then
that's why that's that is an argument
that I just cannot uh she's she's
that's it it makes sense
they need to learn from like a
professional it makes sense
well okay if you say so using the
internet without expressvpn it's like
leaving your laptop open and unattended
at the coffee shop table most of the
time you're probably fine but what if
you turn around one day and your laptop
is gone every time you connect to an
unencrypted Network in a cafe a hotel or
an airport hackers on the same network
can access your personal data doesn't
take a genius to hack someone all you
need is cheap Hardware hackers can make
up to a thousand dollars per person
selling personal data on the dark web
that's why I use expressvpn expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that hackers can't steal your data it
would take a pack of supercomputer over
a billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption so it's pretty safe
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use as
well just fire up the app and click one
button plus it works on all devices so
you can stay secure on the go secure
your online data today
expressvpn.com Matt walshow and get
three extra months free that's
expressvpn.com Matt walshope
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
of course it doesn't make sense at all
it doesn't make sense on multiple levels
um the first being you know
even if the school is staffed with
experts on sexuality whatever the hell
that means that still would not make it
you still have not explained why it's
appropriate
why the school is a place for those
kinds of conversations
if there could be something such as a
human sexuality expert
um you still have not explained
why we're putting them in schools
and
how it could possibly be appropriate to
have those conversations with an
eight-year-old
because it's not school's not the place
for that
um just because the kids are there
it doesn't mean that you are justified
in uh just talking to them about
whatever you want to talk to them about
but then also teachers are not experts
in these subjects
you don't need to be on any you don't
need to be a subject matter expert on
any subject to teach you in a public
school system you don't
like the people that are teaching
mathematics to to sixth graders these
are not these are not expert
mathematicians
and the you know reality is that if if
they were they probably wouldn't you
know it's like it's a cliche but those
who uh can't do teach and there's like
some truth to that
it's not always the case
but oftentimes it is if you're an actual
scientific expert you're probably not
teaching science in third grade
I got a lot of respect people to teach
science in third grade but it's not that
you're not a you're not a scientific
genius necessarily just because you're
doing that
and that's especially the case when it
comes to sexuality
there's not experts in these subjects
again even if they were wildly
inappropriate
grotesque
abusive to be having these conversations
to little kids
with little kids in the in a school
system
but they're also not experts in that
just a fact this is something maybe the
left doesn't understand
just because you're a a deviant you're
you're like a sex-obsessed deviant
and you have lots of different kinds of
sexual encounters it doesn't make you a
sexuality expert
if anything it's quite the opposite
because you're so consumed by your own
deviancy your own perverse desires your
own fetishes that you couldn't possibly
be an expert you you can't think
objectively about this you're just
you're just you're uh
you're consumed by it mentally and
spiritually
again certainly not an expert
and I'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
thanks for uh hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]